[موسيقى]
هذه المقاتله دخلت الخدمه في سلاح الجو
البريطاني في عام
1954 لتكون المقاتله الاعتراضيه الاساسيه
للمهام النهاريه كانت تعد اسرع مقاتله في
هذا الوقت بسرعه بلغت 1170 كيلو متر في
الساعه اي ما يقرب من سرعه الصوت تم تصليح
هذه القاذفه باربعه مدافع رشاشه من عيار
30 مليم هذا الامر منح قوه غير مسبوقه
حينها في المواجهات الجويه القريبه كما
زود الطرازات لاحقه منها بقنابل وصواريخ
عيار 70 م
[موسيقى]
استخدمتها القوات البريطانيه في الحرب على
مصر في معرف بالعدوان الثلاثي في عام
1956 كما استخدمتها ايضا الهند
[موسيقى]
اشترتها دول عربيه عده مثل السعوديه
والكويت وعمان وقطر والعراق والاردن
ولبنان كما تمكن الطائره العامله بالجيش
اللبناني من اسقاط مقاتله اسرائيليه في
عام 1960 في حين اسقطت مقاتلات اخرى من
نفس التراث في سلاح الجو العراقيه ثلاث
مقاتلات اسرائيليه
[موسيقى]